تسرب الغاز الذي سجل قبله سواحل السويد
ودنمارك في سبتمبر الماضي ناتج عن تخريب
تعرض له بنقل الغاز نور دستريم من روسيا
الى المانيا الخلاصه توصل اليها الاذاعه
العام في السويد وكشف عن اكتشاف المتفجرات
على عدد من الاجسام التي وصفها بالغريبه
واكتشفت في منطقه التسرب
معنا من لندن الخبير الاقتصادي في مجال
النفط والغاز والطاقه الدكتور سلامه ممدوح
اهلا بكم دكتور ممدوح الجزء ربما من اللغز
تم فكه على الاقل ادعاء السويدي لكن لم
نتوصل نتوصل التحقيقات الى الطرف الذي يقف
وراء هذا التخريب بدايه برايك ما تاثير
هذه الخلاصه السويديه على الازمه
المتساعده بشان سليمان والازمه السياسيه
انجازات التعبير حول هذا الخط
اولا عدم اشتراك
ممثل عن روسيا في التحقيقات السويديه
يثير الشك بمن كان وراء عمليات التخريب
هذه ناحيه انا اعلم من كان
او ان الادله تشير من كان وراء عمليات
التخريج ااه
نور
هو كان صلب امبابات الغاز الروسي الى
المانيا والى اوروبا ولكن روسيا اوقفت
عبره
قبل عملي
وبالتالي
المعروف ان عمليات التخريب كان المقصود
بها وقف
تعامل بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وبين روسيا في
ما يتعلق بامبابات الغاز الروسيه
ممدوح تاكد وفقا لتحقيق السويدي انه
بالفعل هناك همم طرف ليس مسكوك التي اتهمت
بريطانيا تحديدا ان كان طرف او ان تم
بريئه موسكو هل يفهم ان الهدف كما تشير هو
قطع هذه العلاقه الطاقيه بين موسكو اوروبا
طبعا
روسيا لم يكن لها اي اصبعين في ذلك لان
هذه ماذا تدمر خطا انفقت الكثير عليه في
حين اما بامكانها وقف الانجازات الغازي
الى اوروبا بدون اي تدوير الخط ا معروف من
كان وراء عمليات الضغط
اذا اردتيني قد اذكر ذلك ولكن بناء على
الادله الظاهره لدينا الدكتور محمود
انه ان الدوله التي قامت في هذه العمليات
هي الدوله التي كانت تعارض منذ ايام
الاتحاد السوفياتي وفيما بعد روسيا على
همم تع
بناء خطوط للنفط والغاز
لابدانات الغاز والنفط الروسي الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ناحيه ثانيه
الدليل هو من يستفيد من ذلك هذه الدوله
التي تصدر كميات لا باس بها من ال ام جي
الغاز السائل الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وثا هي
الدوله التي تريد ان تقطع كليه اي اعتمادا
للاتحاد الاوروبي على روسيا اهلا وسهلا
هذه الدلائل تشير الى الولايات المتحده
بغض النظر من القوم بالعمليه الحافز
والدوله التي لديها الحافز والهرس
لتدمير هذا الخط هي الولايات المتحده شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور ممدوح سلامه الخبير في
مجال النفط والت